foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the pots
Moving and Storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
and amazing relationships George
Campbell Ramsey personality co-host of
the very very popular smart money happy
hour here on the Ramsey Network it's a
podcast with he and Rachel he's my
co-host today we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Joyce is going to
start off this hour with us in Chicago
hi Joyce welcome to the Ramsey Show
thank you hi Dave and George hey what's
up I'm so excited to be on your show and
a little nervous too oh that's okay
we've never lost a patient how can we
help
hey um I just wanted some clarification
about
um the advice that you give get and
collections
seems to contradict what you say about
other debt and I'm just curious as to
why that is different
okay I think I know where you are but
let me make sure you mean uh suggesting
people settle it versus like if you have
a student loan I suggest you pay it
right okay I'm making sure I knew which
type of advice that was in Conflict
you're asking okay to start with
um the it might help to know that uh the
full breadth of the advice would be if
you have the money and the entire bill
is legitimate and it's in collections
pay it
is Our advice
okay I don't suggest people settle debts
except those that are broke now if you
have a hundred thousand dollars in
student loan in medical debts let's say
and they're uh and you're calling me to
say gosh I think I'm bankrupt
I've got ten thousand dollars
well you're not bankrupt you need to
settle each of these for 10 cents on the
dollar that way they you gave them
everything you had
and you cleared the debt honorably and
that settlement is obviously voluntary
on their part
but the other thing that comes into play
Then is have they doubled the bill or
tripled the bill with collections fees
or a bunch of other things because
sometimes you start out with a thousand
dollar bill and 18 months later it's
eight thousand dollars with these people
and so I'm gonna go back and settle down
to the original bill for sure I'm not
going to get extorted just because it
went into collections but uh from a
moral construct if you give them what
you have and they will accept that in
settlement then that's a new that's a
fair deal okay so and the way I know I'm
okay with my ethics on that is this I
reverse it because I hear in your I
don't hear uh adversary in your voice so
I'm just kind of teaching with you if
there's adversary we'll go back to that
in a minute but I I just hear a sweet
lady asking a question and so
um
the uh uh uh so the other thing is if I
reverse it okay I have a company that 20
plus years ago advertised on this radio
show
oddly enough the name of the company was
integrity.com
okay I mean they had the website for
integrity right and uh they decided that
they weren't going to pay us forty
thousand dollars
and they got in financial trouble
and I still have not gotten my forty
thousand dollars that integrity.com I
would imagine they're all gone whoever
that was long gone right so I'm not
worried about it but it's irony of
ironies I love the story because of the
name but if they called me today and
said listen we're broke
but we're trying to go back and do right
by these bills
and it's 20 years later I could have
added a lot of interest I could add a
lot of legal fees I could have done a
lot of stuff right but if they said look
we we will give you four thousand
dollars to settle this bill if you will
accept that
and I'm on the receiving end of this I'm
taking the four thousand dollars because
the probability of me getting anything
out of these people ever while I'm
breathing This Side of Heaven is zero
exactly and so I'm happy to get not
because not because necessarily in that
case that they're of bad character
although they might have been I don't
remember that part of the story but but
it's just irony I didn't get paid by
integrity.com but the uh but but you
know but but but if if I think
somebody's broke and they're trying to
be honorable and will settle with me on
what they owe me I'll take it a because
I'm probably not getting anything else B
because I want to set them free
okay and if I want to swap that and say
gosh I got ten thousand dollars to my
name I got a hundred thousand dollars in
bills this Hospital's looking at me
going you're a bankruptcy looking for a
place to happen right then they're gonna
say Hey you know we've already gotten a
lot of money out of the insurance
company and we're gonna let this little
hillbilly go we're going to let him
settle this for pennies on the dollar
then that is Honorable but you didn't
have the money to pay the bill and just
refused with a student loan thing I'm
getting these calls I got 90 000 bucks
in the bank I owe 80 000 and I'm waiting
around to see if Biden's gonna forgive
it and I signed up for the student loan
see I think that's morally wrong
I do too I agree completely do you have
that Joyce I'm curious or is this just
more hypothetical
you know I listened to your show every
day just all day
and um I just have noticed these
um just a little bit of a contradiction
and I just was just you know just
curious because I'm all about if you buy
something you pay off your debt yeah
yeah you're old school I I'm old school
like you the difference is where what
you're getting what you're getting and
that's what I thought was happening and
thank you so much for your question
because it lets me tell millions of
people where we really stand so your
question did that for me thank you but
the uh uh the difference is I'm also a
crusader on the behalf of the
downtrodden the person who's hurt and
hurting and beat up and broke and scared
and terrorized and these collectors are
calling them every day 10 times a day at
work and two of them got fired last week
because the collector called him so many
times the boss didn't want to work in
there anymore this kind of stuff we work
with these people all the time so my
love for the collection world is really
really low I like yeah
yeah because I think
but that doesn't
doesn't mean you shouldn't pay your bill
even if they're jerks
absolutely if you've got the money but
if it's going to take you 152 years to
pay your bill versus settle it and
they'll settle it and you've got them a
little bit of money and you're willing
to give them that little bit of money
I'll help you beat the crap out of them
because they're jerks
and the lenders they already lost their
money they've sold it to the collectors
the collectors are trying to collect to
make profit they bought four cents on
the dollar so it's a different scenario
that's a valid point that's a really
good point to bring up but it's still
morally her her Bugaboo she's a moral
person and I agree with her yeah is if
you signed up for that credit card debt
you ought to pay it pay it right but I
don't have the money a lot of the times
it's medical debt which I have more
empathy for because no one goes to the
hospital going I'd love to take on fifty
thousand dollars but a credit card
you're you're right about the credit
card the medical sells for 10 or 15
cents on the dollar usually medical debt
I mean credit card debt you can buy it
for a nickel on the dollar if it's 36
months old wow and so you know in other
words five dollars will buy a hundred
dollars worth fifty dollars will buy a
thousand dollars worth of credit card
debt and these guys buy this these
accounts in Mass for a nickel on the
dollar and then go try to collect the
whole thing uh which again that doesn't
really view the fact you morally owe the
debt but when you're negotiating with
them that's handy to know yeah they're
still making profit one way or another
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
thanks for joining us America open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you are joining us
for our last segment our last caller
George and I were talking about Joyce
off air we how much we appreciated her
call that was such a cool call it had a
lot of classes it was different B she
was not me or angry or trolling she just
really loves what we do and was worried
about us being inconsistent because she
wants to be a fan and we love being
consistent if nothing else I mean man I
love the opportunity to clarify
something then if you don't agree with
me at least it's for the right reason
that's true if you want to hate me do it
for the right Reason Not For some reason
you read on the internet because
everything on the internet is true
Abraham Lincoln said that one of my
favorite quotes from him on Twitter
that's why I love it yeah it comes up
quite often here we go today's question
is sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services spring is here and it's
time to handle those projects that have
been on pause neighborly has top quality
home service providers like Mr Handyman
Glass Doctor Precision garage door
service and shelf Genie I think I need a
shelf Genie George so uh find the local
help you need at neighborly.com today
today's question comes from Drew in
Austin he writes I hear you guys on the
show talk about being quote house poor
and not spending more than 25 percent of
your take-home pay on your mortgage
payment can you explain more of what
house poor means and what's bad about it
in today's real estate market that is
tough to do with high home prices higher
interest rates Etc what is the harm of
paying 30 to 35 percent if that's what
it takes to get into a house these days
especially since it is only going to
appreciate in value
well this is interesting it's a good
question number one the idea of the
house appreciating value doesn't change
the numbers of you have this much income
and this much of your world is being
taken up by that house payment
and so that's what being house poor
comes down to you don't have enough
money left over to do all the other
things like fund college fund retirement
go on vacation upgrade the car cover the
emergencies and so being houseboor just
means that you have too much of your
world wrapped up in that mortgage
payment and that's too many Americans
today
there's a reason that people have a car
payment if they have a 35 percent of
their income going to house payment they
don't have room in their budget to save
up and pay for a car so they go into
debt so house poor means I borrowed so
much on my house that I end up borrowing
on other things oh and my kids in the
future they'll have student loans
because I didn't save for their school
oh and anything I get ready to do that I
don't have room is George said
economists call the room in your budget
the margin in your budget your
disposable income the income you have
for saving and for investing and for
enjoying and if after your debt payments
you don't have any disposable income any
margin left any wiggle room left in your
budget you're going to end up in our
society going into debt and so Drew let
me tell you one other thing I appreciate
your call or your email in today's real
estate market it's tough to do with high
home prices higher interest rates that
is a phrase I have heard
since I went on the air in 1992.
every year
someone says but Dave
I live in California and we don't use
math here
Dave I live in New York and math doesn't
count here because it's so expensive
that we don't have to follow
mathematical
facts we can just borrow and say oh it's
expensive to live here oh interest rates
are high and I want a house and so but
your the the downstream result of that
is that that
you're going to find yourself lacking in
Investments
and lacking in kids college funds as
George said and lacking in money for
emergencies so everything that happens
in your life is a potential new debt
because you went so far in debt in the
name of getting a house because you
rationalized and said well the world has
never been like this well honey the
world has always been like this
I'm old and it's always been like this
house prices have when my parents bought
their first home in 1962
twelve thousand
250 big dollars you can't buy a used car
for that much these days three and a
quarter percent interest rate and you
know what they got 8 30. my grandfather
had a fit you're gonna be in debt for
30. have you lost your 30-year mind
old people back then thought you were
sinning if you went that far in debt
well you're buying a coffin at that
point yeah 30 years a long time yeah
like what's wrong with you people that
was the reaction of the generation
before my parents right yeah but they
signed up for 30 years at 12 000 and
man I mean my first apartment rent was
235 dollars a month wow you can't even
what you'd have to get nine roommates to
do that you can't cross the threshold
for that that's unbelievable they won't
even let you go look at an apartment
you know but that but it didn't matter
in those days my pay was different
and guess what the overall the cost of
goods was different gasoline was a buck
26. okay when that rent was there so
it's all relative in Russia and ratios
and so
um not picking on you and giving you a
boomer line here you just don't
understand youngin but you just don't
understand young and it's always been
this way
it's always been high yeah and you
always have to make a decision to say no
so later you can say yes live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give like no one else Hallie Haley is
with us rather in Fort Wayne Indiana hi
Haley how are you
I'm great how are you better than I
deserve what's up
I was just wondering if um we should pay
off our car with the profit from our
home sale
why wouldn't you
um because where we don't have
anywhere like we're going to be living
with his mom
um
saving for a while there's no end date
to living with her
how long have you been married I do
um eight years
so what is the profits from the home
sale
um it should be from 50
. okay and why'd you sell your house
basically because we can't afford it
okay and how much is your car debt
it's around 16 000. and what's your
household income
he makes around 58 000 a year
and you have three kids
two kids two kids okay do you work
outside the home Haley no I do not okay
all right so if you were to pay off your
car uh that that would leave you forty
thousand dollars forty two thousand
dollars to be precise correct
okay and you if you went and rented a
house
why do you have to live with your
mother-in-law what you do wrong
I'm asking what you guys did wrong I
mean
I you're you're you're like grown-up
adults with a sixty thousand dollar job
and two kids and you have no debt and
forty two thousand dollars in the bank
you should not have to live with your
mother-in-law
well it'd be really hard to buy a house
basically um
I said go rent that's options
yeah he hasn't thought about that at all
I mean that probably sounds like a waste
of money basically
I don't know so is a divorce
no I ain't living with my mother-in-law
Haley with no ending
fourth time living with her
yeah why has this become the hammock why
is this real life why is this a pattern
I don't know the thing is with Mom has
said that she would give us two acres
um two acres is not enough room
of like somehow being able to build like
a barndominium but now we're at the
point where he's like well maybe we can
we can own it which I've been trying to
be open to but having two young kids I'm
like yeah it sounds like kind of small I
think your husband needs to choose
reality and the reality is we can't
afford the dream Barn dominium we have
to rent for a while while we keep saving
you know listen mom's not the answer to
your future Prosperity you and your
husband developing a game plan is the
answer to your future Prosperity every
time we run home to her for future
Prosperity your life gets worse not
better
okay did I miss something
hell no please go read something
inexpensively take five jobs you pick up
a side job that you can do from home
while the kids are there you guys get to
work make some more money pile up some
money to add to the 42 and go get you a
nice little house that you can afford
quit running home to Mama you're too old
that's what I would do this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
there
one guarantee and shipping is always
free see why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
Georgetown Ramsay personality host of
The George Campbell YouTube channel
which has more than its share of snark
we have too much fun on there one of
Georgia's most endearing qualities this
incredible level of snart we all have
our gifts Dave that's it what's yours
you're functioning in yours I'm um
um at least what you've been told your
gifts are
I don't know that was self-proclaimed
humility yeah that's it yeah that's it
no not really yeah we'll just move right
along George it's good open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five check out George's YouTube channel
though uh Alyssa is with us in South
Bend Indiana hi Alyssa what's up
hi
um I was wondering what type of things
account I should open for a new baby oh
when's your first baby due
um she actually was just born in March
well congratulations what'd you have
little girl you said right
yep awesome that's very cool cool so
when you talk about savings are we
thinking College
um I'm not sure completely like I don't
know you know if I use it for Education
because we looked at like an Indiana 559
plan since we're here in Indiana uh but
I'm not sure if it's going to be for
call just kind of something for when
she's older
um she was getting some money when she
was born and for baptism and we don't
really want to spend it how much
um so I have about 500 and we're still
on baby step two
um but by the time she's like five years
old we'll probably contributing more
aggressively towards this okay we had
two accounts for our kids
one was their little miscellaneous
little savings account
which is which is what you're talking
about and then two we had a College Plan
the College Plan was uh and today if I
had done it it would be a 529 and it
wouldn't be with Indiana pre wouldn't do
prepaid Ed instead I would just do a 529
savings in mutual funds and get you a
smart investor pro at
ramseysolutions.com to help you do that
don't do that with the money we're
talking about right now the money we're
talking about right now is you just open
up a savings account and actually the
baby can't have a savings account until
they're 21. you have to be 18 to do
contract law in any state in the Union
and so when a kid has an account at a
bank it's actually in their parents name
as or in the kid's name with a parent as
a custodian or someone as the custodian
so you're the custodian of the account
so you just run down there open a little
savings account if you want to do high
yield that's fine it's not the money the
amount of money this account makes is
not important and then what we used that
account for was
it started as a place that if they got
absurd amounts of money that a
four-year-old doesn't need we throw it
in that account like if somebody gave
him 50 bucks or something you know that
four-year-old don't know what they're 50
bucks so we're gonna throw that into a
little savings account okay five dollars
you can go get you some candy or
whatever but 50 bucks is crazy so 500
bucks is crazy right they can't because
they can't make the distinction at that
age of the value of judgment so we're
just piling that money up and so by the
time they got up with miscellaneous over
gifting at birthdays or whatever that
kind of stuff small amounts usually less
than a thousand dollars but too much to
give them for candy money it had built
up to where they had sometimes a couple
thousand dollars in there
okay a little bit at a time and then
when they we started training them on
the financial peace junior system where
we had three envelopes for your daily
weekly chores and you got paid
commission uh one of the envelopes was
for saving and what you were saving for
at our house was for your first car
I'm taking care of your college with my
savings plan for your college over here
on the other side but you're saving for
your first car and our deal was that we
told them we would match it
and so save like crazy because you got
401 Dave going here
okay and so each of the kids saved up
money and then whatever they saved up I
matched that Sharon and I matched that
and bought them their first car and so
like Denise our oldest was the first one
out and they always get the worst deal
because it takes them a little while to
break the ground and
um I think she saved up like five
thousand bucks or four thousand bucks we
got a little eight thousand dollar nice
Mustang it was nicknamed Waldo because
when she parked it and forgot where it
was we always said where's Waldo right
in the mall parking lot right and so um
you got to give a car a name when you're
a teenager yes right and the worst the
car is the better the nickname has to be
exactly and then uh Rachel Ramsey Rachel
Cruz she's now known as uh saved up a
little more than that and I was looking
at a really bad idea of a car we went
and drove it and she hated it thank God
and but she had it on her wall for eight
months and then we drove it and it's
like it's horrible it was an Xterra
horrible car did Survivor make those
possible I don't know they're real
popular yeah I mean
getting a used Beamer which is a lot
better car for the same money and
um you know it was a little it was like
a ten thousand dollar Beamer it was not
super expensive then the little brother
he's kind of watching all this so I'll
go ahead and tell the whole story listen
so you can just all the way down the
siblings right if you're gonna tell them
you're gonna match recommendation
parents put a limit on it because the
little guy might save up 30 grand you
know business minded and uh then you got
a 60 Grand car with a 16 year old I
don't think so so he did he saved up a
ton of money and I said honey
no 16 year old driving a car that
expensive in our house because you're
going to tear the freaking thing up
because you're 16 and you're an idiot so
you're not going you're not driving a
car that expensive so we got to get you
a different car but I'm still going to
match it and you can do something else
with the money and he's a Ministry
Mighty kid he gave it uh to an orphanage
wow in in uh in Columbia what a guy yeah
and so um you gave a huge gift to 16
years old huge that's incredible yeah
and got him a nice little Jeep so he
still got the Jeep to this day he's had
several cars since then but I bought the
Jeep back from him later because I
wanted it now it's sentimental then I
gave it to him it's probably worth a
hundred dollars now but I gave it back
to him as a as a graduation gift yeah so
he's got it in the garage right now so
that thing's still around but that's the
whole story on it the the point being
that you kind of still need a goal for
it I don't ever like a savings account
to have no goal so you've got an
emergency fund you've got a car fund
you've got a college fund you've got a
whatever fund and you could your kid
could be saving for college that's okay
but this is not just a general account
and then I decide I don't want to buy
like eight thousand dollars or Skittles
because stupid people will do that
sometimes and you can't just allow them
to do that this is a parenting tool it's
not an actual financial transaction well
a lot of people Dave they're going well
I don't know if my kid's going to go to
college so I'm just going to create an
investment account and that way they can
use it on whatever they want so that's
kind of a new way of thinking for a lot
of people but the with the new secure
act 2.0 we can actually roll over those
529 plan college funds into a Roth IRA
in case they don't use it if you don't
use it at all but the other thing is you
can use it for tech school
and you can use it for other types of
Education other than full iOS of
University right you can use it for a
lot of stuff and here's an idea after
high school if you quit learning
if you never learned anything else after
high school you're what's known as dumb
that's a problem so you need to keep
learning don't be a dimwit keep learning
I don't care where you keep learning or
how you keep learning I'm okay with
certain personalities not getting a
four-year degree I'm not a I'm not a
Hotty Toddy one of those people but the
uh hoity-toity or whatever you call it
but the anyway I'm not that I but I I'm
fine with a welder making 120 000 and a
master's degree in sociology making 38
000 so I'm choosing welder okay I'm fine
with that
um so but but that's not a bad choice is
my point but the but this idea that I'm
never going to learn anything else I'm
never going to sit I just taught a
week-long leadership conference with a
whole bunch of the best Minds in the
world called entree Leadership Summit we
just finished last week that's why I
went on the air last week and people
paid a lot of money to be in there that
make a lot of money and that are Big
Business Leaders that were there to
learn from other people learn and read
learn and read learn and read grow
invest in yourself so that's important
very important very important a lot of
stuff going on in this call but yeah
you're you're right it's more about the
principles like you mentioned Dave but
it is a baby in a bathwater thing to say
I'm never you know higher education has
lost its mind the student loan crisis is
out of control the prices are ridiculous
and some of the degrees offered are
absolutely freaking useless so I'm going
to abandon the whole idea of Education
well that's dumb don't be dumb about
education everything I just said was
true but that's not a reason to abandon
the whole idea of being smarter of
course you want to be smarter so yeah
you so yeah 529s are just fine but and
you can change the name too go to
another kid yeah you can move someone's
got to go to another sibling one of them
is going to take care of the rest of you
so
um
raise the principles give save spend
Flex those muscles and they'll be okay
they'll be all right this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host
so nine months ago we told you that the
real estate market was going to slow
down it was not going to crash the
prices were going to go up but not as
much as they had been
and that there was going to continue to
be a shortage of housing versus the
number of buyers out there looking and
it turns out nine months ago we were
right feels good you're right feels good
not because I told you so but just not
to say I told you so but I told you so
there you go so
hey the job market the economy
everything's kind of in a funk the real
estate market has slowed down the
interest rates have gone up it feels
like it's in a big funk
the weird thing is it's not houses are
still selling they're taking about twice
as long as they used to but they were
selling in 30 minutes and now they're
selling in about 60 days and there's
more houses on the market because the
market has slowed down but there was
nothing on the market before some price
ranges in some areas there's complete
shortage there's nothing for sale in a
certain price range in a certain area so
if you want someone to show you the best
neighborhood schools someone to walk you
through the best places to eat someone
to put you on the right foot when it's
talking about getting a house you need
to get a real top-notch high octane high
protein real estate agent not just any
agent that got his license three weeks
ago I'm talking about somebody sells
hundreds of houses knows what they're
doing and if you want an agent that'll
do more than just find you a home
connect with a Ramsey trusted real
estate agent they're local experts who
we have vetted to be some of the top
sales people in their area they're that
because they get houses sold and they
help you find a house if you're Buy fire
we can connect here with the Ramsay
trusted agent all over the country
there's thousands of them and we spend a
lot of money a lot of time vetting them
and making sure they're the right kind
of people go to ramsaysolutions.com
local agents I'm proud of these folks
they do a good job for you listeners
that's ramseysolutions.com
local agents works that way Bill's with
us in Cincinnati hey Bill what's up
hey Dave hey George I want to thank uh
thank you for taking my call the
question I have for you is uh debt free
except for mortgage payment a new
mortgage that we took out back in
October currently I'm maxing out my 401
401K contributions and wondering if I
should either cut those down or maybe
pause them to try to get the mortgage
payment down what's your household
income and paid off
how about 150 175 and add another layer
I got uh some after-tax Investments and
savings that amount to about
probably about 240 000 uh the mortgage
start at 300 back in October I've been
paying it off down to about 260 as of
this month so if you sold off your
non-retirement assets you could clear
the house
it'll be pretty close I'd probably be
about ten thousand away
hmm I've got about 240 uh in what we'll
call Liquid funds and I've got about I
think 260 left on the mortgage as of as
of you wow why would you not do that
well I think when I talked to other
folks they say about the investment side
that you know basically based on returns
and things of that nature that uh you're
taking a risk from the investment side
of losing money yeah because those are
broke people invested they have
mortgages yeah no that's true yeah yeah
we studied uh 10 000 millionaires the
number of them that told us they became
a millionaire by uh by investing with
money that they borrowed on their house
was uh very dangerously close to zero
like none of them
account but you know as I said other
folks have told me you know be careful
about the returns and things of that
nature so that's why I didn't know if I
should uh you know as I said I'm topping
out the 401K didn't know if I should you
know maybe lower that or it sounds like
the best plan would be to do well I I
you know wait tell folks maybe step four
first right yes so baby step four five
six simultaneous 15 of your income into
retirement
fund some college and whatever's left we
can start paying down the house so are
you doing more than 15 right now
yeah I'm mashing it out so I'm putting
in I'm actually putting in 15 but when
it uh you know at the end it's basically
the max that I can contribute for the
year for this if you're putting 15 in
you're putting the correct amount in
to retirement I would not stop that to
pay off the house faster I would
consider liquidating non-mortgage assets
or non-retirement assets I'm sorry to
pay off a mortgage
um here here's what's going to happen
bill when you get this house paid off
all those dumb people they're telling
you that you're you're not going to hate
it
and if you hate it go get you a new
mortgage
you're not gonna hate it yeah you're
gonna you're gonna feel differently than
you've ever felt in your entire life how
old are you
uh just turn 52 52 way to go and you're
making really good money and you're 100
Dead free but your house you've really
done a good job
seriously if you followed our advice
what's your worst case scenario
yeah and so and I'm telling you we
studied 10 167 millionaires we asked
them what they did to build wealth 89 of
them became millionaires not because of
an inheritance so that means they
systemically systematically somehow
built wealth none of them told us that
they did it with a whole life policy
none of them told us that that none not
one told us that they borrowed money on
their house invested that money and that
caused them to be wealthy which
effectively is what you're doing I mean
honestly it didn't tactically you didn't
go borrow this money you borrowed the
money by the house instead of cashing
this stuff in but balance sheet wise you
understand it's the same mathematical
effect
as if you borrowed on your house to buy
to do those Investments no millionaires
do that none now broke people do it all
the time and people with theory that
don't actually build wealth do all kinds
of crap they tell me they tell me they
buy and sell stocks they tell me they
got rich in crypto they tell me there's
all these people that tell me all these
things but they're a lot like fishing
and golf stories 98 of which we all know
that do either one are lies makes for a
good story though truthfully making 175
with no payments in the world you could
invest another 200 in a few years if you
really want to so I mean in a period of
time you could have paid off the house
you can invest that much more
okay if you say I'm going to cash flow
and pay off 240. then your cash flow
without a house payment would put the
240 back in approximately the same
period of time I mean almost the same
maybe a little less because you'd be
earning on it as you went
okay so um I personally have lived debt
free for a very very long time and
as my old Pastor used to say a man with
an experience is not at the mercy of a
man with an opinion Jason is with us in
Sioux Falls hi Jason welcome to the
Ramsey Show
Dave George how are you guys better than
we deserve man what's up
hey so I need your advice I'm wondering
do I pause the baby steps to cash flow a
wedding absolutely
yes sir
okay what's the wedding gonna cost
um our budget is twelve thousand that
sounds reasonable sure that's very
modest good job
good job sounds like you're marrying
someone with common sense
yes yes for sure more than more than
myself yeah and then I'm also trying to
switch careers
70 grand a year 70.
what's yours
uh right now about 36. okay so between
it's 106 how fast you two are going to
save up 12 Grand
um should be saved up a few months
September yeah awesome so it's not
really going to delay the baby steps all
that much
no but then on the other side of the
wedding we're going to tackle her debt
and I'm trying to figure out when when
to uh make this career switch that I'm
thinking about cool when's the wedding
um October 13th awesomeness good for you
man this is great and you have no debt
but she does
correct I just finished baby step two
very good very good yeah I'm cash
flowing the wedding and then piling up
cash as high as I can pile it up uh and
when we come home from the honeymoon
we'll combine our finances and and
really get after hers real fast and hard
and then we can look at that career
change you got a lot going on right now
yeah
yeah do you need to do that before the
wedding
on the career switch Yeah
uh I don't I don't need to no good um
okay this is a time to this is a time of
great joy
and changing jobs is not always a great
joy
right she as we've talked about it she
has peace about it I have peace about it
um so I think we okay we'll move forward
eventually yeah oh I want you to move
forward I would just say I was just
questioning when sometimes when we try
to do six to good things at once one of
them ends up messing up the other ones
does that make sense
yes sir that's what I'm thinking but uh
you do whatever you want I'm okay hey
cash flow your wedding man you're doing
it I'm proud of you very cool man
there's hope Chargers Oh I thought you
had to spend 100 Grand on a wedding
turns out people are just dumb
example the 12 000 people aren't dumb
the 100 rounds yeah unless you got it
unless you got a couple million anyway
there we go this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the pots
Moving and Storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships thanks for joining
us America George Campbell Ramsay
personality host of The George camel
YouTube show you should check it out
plenty of snark there lots of fun there
you're going to learn something and
you're going to giggle and laugh at
everything and our phone number here
today triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five uh Peter is
with us in Eugene Oregon hi Peter how
are you
hi Dave I'm doing well I'm looking for
some advice
on handling the financial aspects of the
panic that's starting and it's going to
continue around AI artificial
intelligence
or where is the panic
well
uh
first of all they're looking at it as an
existential threat no I I understand all
the all the philosophical panic but
you're talking about a financial panic I
missed any Financial Panic yes
um I worked in uh the AI field for over
40 years and we're turning a lot of
things over to AI including
I'm aware of that where is the financial
Panic actually occurring
it's on Horizon and we're going to see
bank accounts and mortgage paperwork
that's moved around and gets lost and
I'm wondering how to protect ourselves
uh during this transition over the more
Ai and those kinds of errors
can come up
and so okay so there's not any let me
stop a second I just want to make sure
I'm real clear oh yes I don't disagree
with you that AI is a big freaking deal
I'm yeah but but and that there's going
to be a lot of things that we don't even
know are going to happen are going to
happen as a result good and bad by the
way
um there's a lot of reason to be
concerned and a lot of reason to be
thrilled with the potential of AI what
I'm trying to point out is is that there
hasn't been any Financial Panic happen
yet
Yes except in people's minds
are there things that I can do
where I can
what sort of documentation what do I
need to get together
all right for to protect yourself for
what in particular
um and uh paperwork that's at the bank
uh it's not beyond the scope that uh
what I have in the bank could be
transferred over to someone else who has
a name close to mine who lives in
Timbuktu right uh so do you keep do you
keep banking records other than digital
um
I keep some okay all right they keep
trying to get me to go digital and I'm
thinking well should I go back to asking
them to send me paper copies of
everything or just hit print
yeah uh is it is that I mean if you want
to if you want to put a discipline in
place for a period of time because
you're concerned about that if you hit
print that's fine
um I I do not
um
okay
unless the entire civilization as we
know it is collapsed by AI which I'm not
willing to go with that scenario but
unless that occurs the mass transfer of
banking assets to the wrong people is
not going to happen now it can is there
going to be some of that oh absolutely
there is some of that today you have
eight dollar an hour people coding some
of this crap and it gets in the wrong
account now escrow accounts I bet you I
bet you 40 percent of them are out of
balance they can't even seem to divide
their insurance and taxes by 12 and
properly charge it into the mortgage
payment so I mean so we've always had a
level of error the question is is do the
institutions is the is the level of
error so massive that it's uncorrectable
if it is I don't think there is a
protection for that if it's minor and
you're the one or the one of the 5 000
customers out 500 000 that had a problem
and you've got to prove it to get your
stuff put back then yeah you probably do
want to protect yourself against that
but you probably ought to be doing that
anyway yeah AI is using data that has it
has been given and so unless your bank
records got hacked and fed into the AI
systems this it feels a little on
verging on paranoia versus the reality I
think the hackers could use AI
to actually actually clean clean out
some accounts to his point I would go
with him on that I don't think that's
paranoia I mean I think the hackers are
I think you're going to see hackers use
AI in a way that we haven't even dreamed
up I mean these buttholes can steal
stuff that's not theirs regularly as it
is this is just going to help them so AI
is going to be uh it's a more efficient
way to do fraud yeah that's what it
amounts to but that doesn't mean that
the bank is going to not be responsible
for your ten thousand dollars that was
in your account before some AI aided
hacker cleans your account out it just
becomes one more way fraud could exactly
more it's more efficient for everyone uh
to you know to do content to create
fraud to violate copyrights or
trademarks or steal images and so you
know if you want to be crooked it's a
more efficient way to be crooked that's
the downside of this technology it's uh
highly Innovative and highly efficient
oh my God it's amazing but also it's got
such a powerful thing for good and it
kind of feels like when the internet was
on the horizon we all went this is scary
but also amazing I think we're just
gonna all adapt yeah but but I think um
to go a hundred percent dark on it and
predict the end of time because of it
I'm as an exit existential threat now
cause I still think humans have this
weird idea that we want to be in control
of crap we're not going to let the
robots take over I just don't think I
mean I don't think we're going to need
Will Smith on this I think we're going
to be all right and so uh because we
just we you know people thinking people
are going wow
powerful tool scary thing but wow the
vehicle versus the horse and buggy
powerful tool scary thing you can run
over the neighbor's dog you hard to do
that with a horse you know I mean it's
uh you know but it but you know there's
a good reminder to actually make sure
you have good passwords and it's not
just password on those old bank accounts
keep your dog out of the street and keep
your dog out of the streets but the uh
um
but the two life units I mean it's two
life hacks but no he's he's right that
um there's some scary things what I
don't want to do and what I was trying
to push in there is uh we don't want to
add to the idea that there's already
some kind of like stocks are have lost
value in anticipation of what AI is
going to do let me give you an example
of that okay
Y2K
anybody remember that old people young
people Kool-Aid drinkers are you out
there why 2K yes yes we're always going
to come to an end I have a friend who
wrote a book about the end of the world
on why 2K made millions of dollars doing
it big best seller huge best seller
he's reading several bestsellers since
then none of them were like I was wrong
about Y2K but anyway but yeah and uh did
I mean but did stocks go down they went
down what happened in January when the
fireworks went off did the grid shut
down did the world shut down no nope
what happened
nothing stocks went right up through the
roof January that year was one of the
best years ever look up January
2000. you'll love it this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
all right
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
this is the Ramsey Show
for 30 plus years we've been here on the
air
answering the same questions exactly the
same way eventually someone will hear us
in times for it to click okay 7000 is
the rule yeah so uh hey we got people
who tune into every episode of the
Ramsey Show and they know everything we
teach about money and they still feel
stressed out and stuck why because
knowing what to do is different than
doing it
oh
knowing what to do is different than
doing it like the mute button it does
there we go yeah I carried it out I
couldn't figure out where that was
coming from okay uh yeah personal
finance is 80 Behavior the problem with
my money is the guy in my mirror
if I can get him to behave he can be
skinny and Rich but he has issues he
likes Donuts
chocolate oh wait a minute
wait a minute this is not my personal
counseling session I'm sorry okay The
Proven way to change your behavior with
money is by getting in a situation where
you're accountable and encouraged by
other people turns out it is not good
that men be alone remember the fouchy
quarantine I remember the faucy
quarantine it's not good that men be
alone no one liked being alone we went
full we passed away people got fat went
crazy and remodeled their houses it was
not good you know and so it is not good
that man be alone now The Proven way to
do it getting into Financial Peace
University class 10 million people have
done that and what happens is not only
do we teach you the things you should
have been taught when you're in high
school and no one teaches except us in
high school so there you go and in case
you know not only but just knowing it
doesn't do it so the teachings so you
need to be in a group in a class whether
it's virtual or in a local church and
that's why this class has worked for
millions of people go to Financial Peace
University
ramseysolutions.com FPU
and Let Me Tell You Folks it's the best
time you'll spend because you'll break
some habits that some of you have had
for 23 years oh 23 years was I talking
to you must have been must have been
God's voice did you hear it yeah
ramseysolutions.com FPU that was a joke
calm down for those of you hear them
freaking out those of you that are
oversaved calm down but the um so George
guess what I found out what's that the
state of Florida
is genius okay at least at least on one
thing they have passed a law they're one
of 22 States now that has a mandatory
personal finance requirement to graduate
from high school
just went through and the school boards
are all going around now the districts
are all going around and we are at
Ramsey the foundations and personal
finance Ramsey curriculum for high
school students our personal finance
stuff is one of just a handful of
approved curriculum we got our final
Florida approval this week we meet all
the standards we meet all the standards
all the backup it's awesome and so your
local District if you're in Florida has
the requirement to teach something and
they can choose
hours so if you want if you're in
Florida and you want your kid or if
you're just in Florida and you want kids
in general to go through young teenage
brilliant people to go through uh
foundations and Personal Finance contact
your local district and say hey we want
Ramsey we want Ramsey we want Ramsay if
you're going to protest with pitchforks
and uh and like uh torches and
everything do it for a good cost you
ought to just do something positive
because you know how many times somebody
calls a School Board District or school
board or the school district and says
something positive
that's none none this is like calling
your preacher and giving him a
compliment they never get one yeah I
don't care what was wrong with the
sermon we don't like you got this
curriculum we don't like this book in
the we don't like this we don't like
just what we like is we like Ramsay in
our schools and we would like it to be
there and you have to teach something
you might as well teach you so call them
Florida call your districts and let them
know there's a big gap in those
curriculums because some of the other
ones Dave they're teaching all about
credit and the importance of the credit
score and how to lead this life of debt
it's exhausting so we're out here now we
could complain but no we were trying not
to complain but trying to be nice
Maryland's in Houston Texas hi Maryland
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi George hey what's up thank
you so much thank you for answering my
call sure uh I need some help with a
decision before I make it okay
um me and my husband would like to know
should we sell our rental and our land
we have a rental property we have some
land and we also have my mother-in-law's
home we need to sell uh to pay off our
principal and the home we live in it's a
newer home we bought it new would you
share some numbers with me please how
much do you owe on your present
residence
what is your land worth
my land I got a call today and they
trying to get me to sell it for 20 000.
okay although I was asking for 35. what
is the mother-in-law's property worth
two hundred and twenty thousand is it
paid off
it's paid off
paid off here with two nieces oh so what
is your share of the 220.
um
I'm sorry you're getting one third I'm
sorry you're getting one third he's
getting 50 and they're getting 25. okay
so he gets 110 000 out of that okay and
yeah and then you had a rental what
would you get out of the rental
uh the rental uh appraised for two
hundred and ten thousand we have a
mortgage on it how much so we a hundred
and nine we owe okay so you get 100 out
of that all right so 100 110 and 20. uh
would give you enough to pay off your
house but almost but not quite if you
sold all three of those things correct
yes sir okay is and and why are you
wanting to do all that
um because my husband I feel like a
workaholic and he's just driving himself
working working working
and he's 61. he's been on his job 37
years and I'm just ready for him to
relax more so I'm telling him uh you
know I'm I call you guys y'all have any
more money
uh at this point we have our emergency
fund that's all we have right now so you
got rid of all your bills but you still
got no money if you do this right
yeah
and we do have a event that I owe 30 000
on
a Corvette
Corvette okay
that's interesting
well that's because I was working and I
was paying for it but I ended up having
a hip replacement so now I'm at home
still healing but I am paying for it I'm
getting money to pay for it are you
showing off everything inside to pay off
your house and then you're trying to
tell me how you're keeping this thirty
thousand dollar car you're not driving
that you can't even drive by the hip
replacement there's something funny
about a hip replacement in the Corvette
I'm sorry
I gotta climb up in my truck and I'm too
sore to do it today so I know exactly
what you're talking about
okay they
can work 35 000. okay yeah
so
I think if you got rid of everything and
you had the house paid off that'd be an
awesome start but I don't think I don't
you sound like you think you're through
when you do that you've got no money now
you got a paid off house but we're gonna
dig up the bushes to eat
and that's right yeah we're gonna have
to have some money in addition to
getting all this stuff paid off and so I
love the idea of it sounds like you're
cleaning out your closet and having a
garage sale but it's a rather
sophisticated one
you're getting rid of a whole lot of
clutter in your life
and it's a great start but it's not a
silver bullet like Dave mentioned so I
think these are all great things to do
but we still need a game plan of how we
can dessert stop working one day is
there any one of these items you're
talking about selling that you other
than the Corvette that you went oh man I
think we really shouldn't do that we
ought to keep it
no I'm not well my husband wants to keep
the new house he did he worked hard in
the new house the one you live in the
one we lived yeah but we weren't selling
it we were just paying it off right
yeah but I was trying to tell them let's
do the Dave ramseyway and go back to our
house pay it off and say I did off and
we'll set up yeah I don't think that I
don't know where we got that being today
Ramsey Way the Dave Ramsey Way would be
paying off everything by selling
everything keeping the new house and
then work a few more years let's build
us up in this dig you have to work like
a maniac but you do need to be
aggressively saving in the next five to
seven years
of the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today a and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage the
Vikings football team
incredible
tease I don't know where Dave's going
with this because that stage is James is
going the producer's in there going
nobody's on the stage Dave nobody's on
the stage what's going on Dave's safe
palpitation from that yeah
but this is exciting news
is this the first time that you've and
you're the first time we've done a
debt-free screen with an NFL team wow
I've not done one we're not technically
doing one we're just doing it on their
behalf they didn't even ask us to but we
want to give them a big shout out and
congratulations you take it the Vikings
paid off their Stadium what was it 27
years early 23 years early this is crazy
and they saved hundreds of millions of
dollars the Vikings consumed their
mortgage to Valhalla
the writer was having fun with this one
that's good way to go way to go Rider
wow so oh it's Mike Florio no wonder
okay on pro football talk that's where
the article's from okay thanks Mike good
job Mike a new tax bill would
dramatically accelerate the process of
paying off U.S Bank Stadium before July
1st 377 million in Bonds on the building
will be retired at a savings of 226
million in interest
wow
so the Vikings I'll tell you it's a nice
Stadium too you ever been I don't think
I've been I've been there a couple times
and um we've done a bunch of stuff there
in Minneapolis and uh a lot of the
churches and things we work with and
businesses we work with have Suites and
so we've gone a couple times it is a
beautiful Stadium congratulations to the
Vikings it'll be paid off before the
2023 season so they're on the verge so
there and here's here's your invite if
you guys how does a viking scream I'm
debt free probably in a frightening way
whether it's a football player or an
actual Viking still scary but they have
an open invite to come to their deaths
we definitely we wouldn't even make you
uh come here we would allow you to do it
over the phone if anyone from the
Vikings organization wants to uh scream
I'm debt-free we would we would be
honored and if you want to invite us on
the field during the game I think it
might be the only NFL stadium in America
that is paid off I could be these
stadiums are is Jerry Dome paid off
Jerry might have paid off Cherry Dome
he's got the money well yeah there
there's that but I'm not sure you never
know you never know I honestly don't
know but this is the first time I've
heard of this and so
um would you go on the field and do the
debt free scream if they invited you to
open up the season absolutely I think
this is some brilliant on top of that
the Vikings actually win too they're
actually a good football team that's
helpful too so it also helps with their
revenue to pay this thing off you know
that's true winning team that's true we
stayed at the uh we were up there the
last time doing an event we stayed at
the Omni which is right next to their
practice facility and they're and I
walked over with some time I was doing
my walk and I walked over went through
the the museum and no one was in there
but me but it was uh and all these
ghosts of Christmas Past but um a
football pass but it's a fascinating
Museum I mean Fran Tarkington all the
you know the whole thing is just very
very cool very cool so uh Hey way to go
way to go Vikings Vikings are debt free
I like when a Stadium's not desperate
for Revenue now they can actually make
you know make the experience great for
the fans and not Jack up prices on the
hot dogs and I'm thinking the prices on
the hot dogs they're still going to be
17. thinking but we're gonna eat for
free when we go are we just because we
did this just because we love Donald
we'll mention you guys on air we're not
above a schmooze for a free hot dog
that's all we're saying but yeah hey
cool stuff very cool uh the Stadium's
already been in existence for seven NFL
seasons hosting a Super Bowl and a final
four and various other events lots of
various other events uh the building is
in first class condition and it is it's
in excellent condition it's a 1.1
billion dollar Stadium it's pretty
amazing it's a beast it really is and
the old one remember in the old days you
probably know the the uh one year they
had the blow up roof type thing over it
oh and it collapsed with too much snow
on it back in the old days this is the
one before this that's Minnesota
problems right there and not issues we
have in Tennessee unless humidity will
collapse something but yeah open phone
Sarah triple eight eight two five five
two two five Connor is with us in uh
Atlanta Georgia hey Connor welcome to
the Ramsay show
good afternoon Dave and George how are
y'all better than we deserve man what's
up
I have been living on rice and beans for
years and I am scared to live a little
how many years oh about six
um currently 22.
um I've I've been in yeah I took your
class in high school my parents taught
me to leave the Ramsay way uh tripped
and fell a couple times but uh I didn't
go to college and just instantly started
saving every penny I made you know
didn't live off time just saved save
save save how much money do you have now
I'm currently about 200 000. good for
you how old are you
22. 22.
you're an old man
and um and what what's your household
income sir about 160 000 a year what do
you do for a living
I am a call truck driver wow you're
killing it okay
um okay let's clarify a couple things
the Ramsay way is live like no one else
so that later
you can live
and give like no one else that's the
Ramsay way not living in a cave and
collecting lint and only coming out on
Triple Coop on Thursday the rest of your
life
that's not the Ramsay way okay so
generosity and enjoyment
should increase as wealth increases
okay and I think you're just stuck on
the saving part of the button aren't you
yeah I'm you know I'm I'm scared to
really touch any of it um yeah we've got
a flat tire so we've got give save spend
that's the only three things you can do
with money and you're great at the
savings part and so what I would do if
I'm in your shoes is I would force
myself to have some goals in the giving
Arena and the spending Arena that feel
frivolous that feel crazy for Connor at
20. oh my gosh I can't believe I'm
spending this much on a vacation I can't
believe I'm gonna tip that waitress a
thousand dollars but man when you do it
it is going to be so freeing Connor uh
if I were to step back if if you were to
step outside of your body for a minute
and just look at your life from a
distance and you were looking at your
whole situation what's something Conor
should be spending money on that he's
not
sure just give me two things there's two
things you are sure you know exactly
what I meant
I mean I'd eventually like a vacation a
vacation what would be an outrageous
vacation for you in your mind
Australia okay and what would you spend
on this outrageous vacation
oh I don't know maybe ten thousand
dollars okay and you have two hundred
thousand right
yeah most of it's tied up though what's
it tied up in
the stock market
in mutual funds or stocks or
uh mainly stocks retirement account
I have 401k about 16 000 that's in full
one it's not tied up if it's in a stock
honey you put in a sell order and you
have the money by tomorrow
it's not tied up at all there's no rope
involved in the stock market they don't
use rope there
sorry okay it's it you're thinking of it
properly as a long-term investment not
something to jump in and out of but
let's pretend that tomorrow you had one
hundred and ninety thousand instead of
200.
would you still be okay
oh yeah okay
so I think George is right maybe even we
baby steps maybe we don't spend ten
thousand maybe we spend five thousand
and we go somewhere other than Australia
because you do need to spend 10 if
you're going to go there but the um but
but you know let's baby step in and say
I'm gonna because what's happening is
Georgia's exactly right the tire's flat
and those muscles haven't been worked
and we need to work a giving muscle
and we need to work a spending muscle so
pick out a number that you're going to
splurge on giving
and find something that makes you cry
hungry children
in the burn Ward or the Cancer Ward I
don't know what is it that makes you cry
and give them some money
and find something for you and take that
same exact amount of money and go do a
trip
and start to build this muscle maybe
find a hobby
Dave picked up golfing no no don't do
that don't do that that'll that causes
all kinds of too much stress there's too
much mental illness associated with that
no but yeah find something that's fun
yeah don't do that this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jill is in Milwaukee
hi Jill welcome to the Ramsay show
[Music]
what's up
um so my husband and I are new to baby
step four and we're wondering if we
should open an IRA for my husband so we
both have matches with our 401 with our
employers 401ks and we're doing that
then after the match I already had an
IRA so I'm maxing that out but we still
have a bit to go to get to our 15 so
we're wondering if it's best to open an
IRA for him or do we go back to our
401ks do the rest in the Roth options or
or what would you recommend you got Roth
options on the 401K so the difference in
a Roth option and a Roth option for an
individual there is no difference as
long as the mutual funds are the same
thing if you've got crummy mutual funds
on the 401K you could do the individual
if you want to do the individual it's
okay but you've Matt you've got all the
mats you can get right
correct yes yeah and I'll tell you what
I did with our Ramsey 401K is we've got
a Roth option here and so for many years
I just used the Roth 401k and did my 15
there and didn't contribute to a Roth
IRA so unless you're you're maxing it
out the income goes up to where you know
you would move to maybe a backdoor Roth
IRA or something like that you could
stick to the Roth 401ks if they've got
good options yeah as long as you've got
good mutual funds in there you're fine
okay sounds good so then um would you
recommend what the amount that I'm
putting into the IRA actually go into my
401k because I have a bigger bucket of
savings there doesn't matter where the
no matter the size of the bucket all
that matters is the quality of the
Investments is your IRA or Roth
it is yes okay no I'd leave it alone
it's fine as long as you've got good
mutual funds the size of the bucket
doesn't change it as long as it's the
total all that you're getting oh you're
making money on every dollar regardless
of where the dollar is laying
now if one mutual fund is losing five
percent one's gaining 15 that's a
different thing right
yeah but in terms of the buckets if
you've got ten thousand dollars in one
in your Roth and you've got 150 000 in
your 401k you have a hundred and sixty
thousand dollars working for you it
doesn't matter which pile it's in
okay all right that makes sense that
doesn't change the math at all so good
question good question hey here's what's
cool Jill you're gonna be rich
you know why you're gonna be rich
because you're paying attention
asking these kinds of questions one
correlating factor between people who
have money they pay attention and they
invest consistently oh that's that
simple they're asking questions like
she's asking broke people don't ask
questions like Joe asked and you know
unless they're trying to not be broke
anymore you know but I mean they don't
but people that do that this intentional
I actually am going to spend some time
learning about Roth IRA putting money in
a Roth IRA instead of re-watching Tiger
King
and these are the people that end up I
mean does anybody really watch Tiger
King but it could happen it's
implausible it could happen I mean is is
is that's so old now it's not even a
joke anymore people don't even remember
it Dave people have been born we've
tried to block out everything from the
fauci covet area oh that's true it's all
a little blurry yeah it's a little
little fouchied up yeah
so open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Matthew is with
us in Phoenix hey Matthew how are you
hey George hey Dave thanks for taking my
call I really appreciate it sure how can
we help
yeah so um I completed a baby step two
about a few months ago which feels great
especially uh doing it for three years
of just work work sleep sleepy and work
more
um I'm now I'm trying to uh stay
motivated and just wondering if you guys
had me tip tip to keep motivated to keep
going through get that baby step three
done how much longer do you got what's
your number now and what are you aiming
at
um I'm at about three thousand dollars
saved now
um and my goal is around 14
000. I was gonna take you
um my goal is probably by December
January at the latest of next year
sounds good of next year are you saying
like a year and a half
no no you're saying six months from now
you're gonna be done
yeah yeah okay okay that's more
reasonable okay good okay and how long
have you been working on this so far
I started um with the whole program or
just on maybe step three
okay
um but I mean how long did it take you
to get out of debt
um it took me about a little over about
three years and four months ah okay all
right so you're tired I get it I'm
catching on okay
um
did you sense something when you got the
debt paid off like did you have a a
celebration moment when that when you
cleared the baby step two
uh yeah I went and went to Taco Bell and
ordered off the dollar menu whoa you go
big go big
so you didn't even like eat like real
food or anything oh my gosh no no I mean
did you not that you're being silly and
I am too but seriously the question I'm
asking is when I got out of debt I could
feel it physically in my chest it was
gone there was a like a used to be a 300
pound guy standing on my chest and he
was gone you know what I'm talking about
yeah I felt like I I lost about yeah 20
pounds just from my shoulders exactly
exactly and that's all joking aside so
what I want to tell you is that when you
finish baby step three you've got the
foundation laid you have an emergency
fund and you have no payments but a
house payment you're going to feel that
in a way you have even more so than just
when you clear a baby step two because
like Dr John deloney talks about our
bodies store the stress of being broke
being broke is having a bunch of debt
and no money and when you don't have any
debt and you have some money called your
emergency fund baby step three you're
gonna look at that and go I have fifteen
thousand dollars and I don't have any
payments there is no wolf at my door
I can breathe you're it's worth it you
can make it six more months to get to
that feeling aim at that feeling that's
where you're going it's going to be like
going up in the mountains and breathing
cool air like if Clark feels good in
your lungs you know what I'm saying it's
Freedom you know what I'm talking about
yes I do yeah breathe that breathe that
that's coming in just by December how
old are you
I am 36. you have done such a good job
and you're almost free
Matthew why I remember this feeling that
you had I've got out of my forty
thousand dollars in Consumer Debt and I
went it was so exciting it's like
whack-a-mole getting rid of those debts
in the debt snowball and then you get to
baby step three and it's a little
discouraging there's no immediate reward
feels like the hardest step you're in
the middle of the marathon saving is
boring you're tired of working the three
jobs and when you're paying off debt
you're making progress back to zero
we're climbing out of the hole out of a
negative net worth getting to Solid
ground but when I reframed my brain and
went oh my gosh I'm now building for the
future instead of paying for the past
that was a game changer for me
emotionally to go oh my gosh I've never
had a positive net worth in my life I'm
changing my family tree General
generational curses are being broken and
that really lit a new fire under me for
a new adventure and so I think that's
part of what you need to do with your
situation you know there's kind of three
things that happen that cause a
tremendous release that you physically
it's a physiological shift one is first
and foremost you get control
get on a budget and you're not bouncing
checks I remember sitting at my desk in
my 20s and um I had missed a check I
didn't write it down and so I'm
realizing I'm getting I've got checks
outstanding and there's not money in the
account that that pit in your stomach my
stomach tightening up sweat in the palm
of my hands across the top of your lip
across the top of your eyes your
adrenaline glands start to release and
you're just like
that that's just Terror that fear comes
over you I remember that since and I
remember thinking never again
never again
never again not someone will be in
control I'm gonna be on a budget I'm
gonna be on a detailed plan I'm gonna be
executing with great great diligence
number two I'm gonna get out of debt I'm
not going to owe a soul you don't have
any payments and you have a plan oh my
gosh and then add to that you've got 15
or 20 000 sitting there for only for
emergencies it's not for a bass boat
it's only for emergencies those three
things will cause your physical symptoms
of anxiety to go down
Dr John deloney can tell you more about
that but that's exactly the truth you'll
get where you can breathe again your
whole you know it's a whole different
world and you're not going from Terror
to Terror to Terror to Terror this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships open
phones this hour George Campbell Ramsay
personality co-host of smart money happy
hour with the one and only Rachel Cruz
on the Ramsay networks and the new
George camel YouTube channel my favorite
part is the snark you don't want to miss
it check them all out the phone number
here is triple eight eight two five five
two two five Daniella is with us in
Albuquerque New Mexico hi Daniela how
are you
hi good grateful to be here
be here how can we help
I'm currently house
away because I want backyard chicken
however in my price range
um I can't really find anything that I
like I'm what I want to put 20 down
um but I just want to know if I'm being
too picky and how do I know if I have
unrealistic expectations
well first thing that comes to mind is
with an HOA there's a bunch of clucks
but that doesn't matter
but I know there was a pun in here so
there had to be something in here I'm
with you I'm not a fan of HOAs although
I am and a few of them Lord Jesus pray
for me help me and
um yeah
I don't blame you uh I'm not sure I want
to buy a house based on chickens but um
what's the heart behind the chicken
ownership
um well most of it is yes I don't want
an HOA and also I just
um want chickens have their own eggs
eventually you know many Homestead sort
of things yeah so you actually watch
something before you're actually looking
for a small piece of ground and not in a
neighborhood more than the HOA issue
because I mean you're not going to
Homestead and have uh multiple farm
animals in a Suburban situation even if
there is no HOA they have stuff called
codes usually
possibly I just know that New Mexico is
pretty lenient on that that's true
that's true in suburbs you know their
neighbors we have goats and chickens and
yeah but neighbors aren't always real
lenient
right I mean a certain number of barn
animals farm animals in a non-farm
situation will go aways but after a
while the neighbors are going to get
whether you got HOA or not somebody's
going to shoot your chickens I mean
they're just only get up at five o'clock
in the morning so um yeah the uh it is
New Mexico so it's a little bit like
Tennessee but the uh uh yeah I think
you're looking for a piece of ground how
much money have you got for your down
payment
um I have 70k good way to go what do you
make
uh I make it ranges but in between
it's good for you and you're single
I'm single I'm 26 years old have you
lived this Farm life before
oh no okay you know what I we had a
Ramsay personality for a while that did
this remember uh Christy Wright's story
oh yeah yeah she's had a great story
about when she was a farmer
that thing you remember and yeah uh you
got to be able to look that one up but
anyway the uh um you know what I would
do I would try to find a place that
allows animals that has like five or ten
acres and rent it for a year
and let's give this a shot
before I invest based on the whole
Homestead Farm animal thing when I've
never done it I might I might try that
um I I recommend that sometimes in
vacation home settings where someone
says you know I've always wanted a beach
house and then they go rent there for a
year and find out their sand
um and on every thing you touch for days
there's sand and you can't get rid of
the sand and they don't I don't want to
live here so um yeah that's what ends up
happening so yeah I think I'd give this
a run as a renter for a year and let's
experiment and see if we do want to live
out a little bit and have a little bit
of acreage and as a 26 year old young
lady be uh be running some farm animals
around that might end up not being as
fun and romantic as it sounds like yeah
and I would be working with a good real
estate Pro as well in your area who can
find these pieces and I mean your
options are going to be more limited and
so you've got to be okay with the
consequences of that choice of going I
want a little piece of land and here's
what I want on it yeah but I do think
you're probably gonna be
uh outside of Suburbia you're probably
going to be just outside of town so to
speak and um you can do that in there
and now Albuquerque that might not be a
bad thing yeah you know it might not be
a bad thing Albuquerque is a great
little town but
um but but there's some pretty areas out
there particularly head over towards
Taos and all that it's beautiful over
towards the mountains so uh it starts to
get expensive over there too by the way
but yeah yeah so just um but but
anytime you've got activities other than
just normal shelter
involved in your housing like Farm or
whatever then let let's I always suggest
giving her a little rent and give her a
little try well our Progressive story
was she got fed up with it in about two
years yeah if I recall well and Dr John
deloney had some chickens and he just
told me there was some kind of like rat
infestation they had to get rid of the
chickens and so his history the other
day yeah his dream of chicken ownership
is gone I have no well it's that's I'm
that's not a credible Source though
John and chickens that's not that's not
credible I take all of his stories with
a grain of salt I think um well yeah the
rat infested yeah so who gets that
deloney uh but yeah Christie's was I
think hers was about I mean she just ran
farm animals and got tired of it and
then decided I wanted to be like in the
city again and so I'm I think she was
glad she didn't own it and it's the end
of the story so
um if I recall I remember hearing the
story a few times so
um that's where we'll go that's how I
would look at it thank you for the call
Tim is in Detroit hi Tim how are you
good how about you guys better than we
deserve sir how can we help
well I'm about 75 or 80 000 in that uh
mix between uh credit cards consumer dot
uh mostly vehicle payment
um this is all not including the house
and looking for your advice on how to
get out of that okay how much do you owe
on the car
uh roughly 38 000. what do you make
uh I bring home about 1100 a week it
fluctuates a little bit but uh 1100 is
about average sell the car
completely insane
I agree yeah you bought way too much car
it's not brought you the joy that you
wanted it to bring you it's brought you
more stress now there's times when you
sit in and turn the key it's joyful for
a moment but then when you remember the
payment it makes you want to throw up a
little in your mouth
no uh question for getting rid of it is
um I've got I think I've heard in the
past you recommend getting a personal
loan to pay off the difference in what
it's worth
um is that what you would recommend
doing or yeah what's it worth 401K no
it's worth about about 28 000. who said
yeah that's what Kelly Blue Book said um
private sale or trade in
I believe that was Private okay how long
you had this car
just over a year you roll negative
equity into it
I did yeah okay that's probably where
you get that far in that fast okay yeah
so you already had the I would get a
personal loan at the credit union for 10
grand and I would sell this puppy and
get you a hoopty that's a good start
because you got a 750 800 car payment
and you make 50 Grand a year uh this is
no fun this is not the definition of fun
I want you to get your life back man and
drive like no one else so later you can
drive like no one else Let's Get You
Where You're not broke anymore and then
get you a good car that's how I would do
it this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
folks you know that sinking feeling when
you make an offer on a house you love
and then you hear there's another offer
you need the Churchill Mortgage home
buyer Edge super fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
well we just finished
the best entree Leadership Summit week
we have ever done last week it was off
the chain
and the weird thing is I can honestly
say the only one better is going to be
next year's and it's going to be I am
absolutely thrilled to announce and a
large number of these tickets are
already sold and I think the hotel that
we're going to is already sold out but
I'm gonna go ahead and announce this
anyway entree Leadership Summit which is
possibly the premier leadership
conference in America today we happen to
do it but it's so good that if I wasn't
doing it I would go as an attendee it's
amazing it's really really good if
you're a business leader investing in
your own growth is something you do our
friend John Maxwell says leadership is
the leadership ability is the lid that
determines a person's level of
Effectiveness you got to invest in
yourself if you want to grow in
leadership
and the premier Conference next year
Entre leadership you're going to be
challenged listen to this top Minds
James Clear of atomic habits
Craig groeschel of Life Church
Mike Rowe of Deadliest Catch and dirty
jobs Carrie Lawrence Kerry was the first
female fighter pilot in American history
and she is a motivational machine she's
something else Dan I'm going to speak to
Dave Ramsey uh Dr John deloney Ken
Coleman next year's Summit will be our
10th year anniversary we're taking over
the Gaylord Texan in Dallas to celebrate
if you want to grow and you want to be
there uh you need to go right now I
think the Platinum tickets are gone the
preferred are almost gone I think the
hotel rooms are gone uh there was only a
there was less than 900 left the other
day and I'm pretty sure we sold them out
but not maybe not only you can check go
to ramseysolutions.com Summit
April 21-24 next year and it's on sale
right now what goes on sale today to the
public so you're the first public to
hear about this
ramseysolutions.com
Summit Andrea is with us in Des Moines
Iowa did I pushed the wrong button I did
Andrea is in Des Moines Iowa how are you
Andrea
I'm great thank you so much for taking
my call David doors sure what's up
so my question is we're in baby step
seven and I was wondering if it's okay
or if it's violating the principles to
get go back into debt for a mortgage to
get a bigger house
so the situation is I've started working
again our household income went up
seventy thousand dollars so we're at
about two hundred thousand dollars
annual income we have a net worth of
about eight hundred thousand dollars and
are more or it's not our mortgage our
primary residents our only resident is
worth 350 about and we have a over
emergency fund about a hundred thousand
dollars in savings and you want to move
from 350 to what
okay and
and a 1300 square feet plus 1100 square
feet finished basement and we have five
kids
um well there's not a uh a principal in
the Ramsey process or baby steps that
prevents you from doing that as long as
the payments no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay
uh on a 15-year fixed
um
I gotta share with you the truth though
I mean you make 200 000 a year sure you
have a hundred thousand dollars saved
you have 350 so that's 450.
um 556 5750 you can do this in three
years if you just save it
and um okay I I personally you know you
delay investing for that to save it
um
I mean you have an 800 000 net worth at
what age
41. yeah you can if you want I I would
have to figure it out because I don't
borrow money and it would be
particularly hard
for me to go back into debt once I had
received personally it's just a personal
observation not a not a not a not a
discussion of the baby steps or the
principles the principles are you can go
do it as long as you do it on 15-year
but I just couldn't do it emotionally
I just couldn't put myself back in there
I I I I I value my freedom more than I
do my style of living
standard of living
yeah that's where we're at my husband is
on team what would Dave do and I'm on
team Dave wouldn't yell at me yeah well
Dave's not going to yell Dave's not
gonna yell at either one of you you're
rock stars I mean you're amazing oh you
can't say rock stars anymore after the
commercials but yeah but anyway you're
amazing you're fabulous and and you've
done a great job you gotta you know
approaching a million dollar net worth
you're making 200 000 a year you got
five kids everything's paid for there's
no Dave yell at you anywhere
but I just gotta I would be sad because
I just couldn't do it emotionally
yeah I just it would just it makes my
stomach hurt a little bit thinking about
it and that mortgage would be we're
talking a four hundred thousand dollar
mortgage so that's that's sizable that's
more than the house is worth they put
down 400 after fees spring maybe 300 but
still and but then you could pay it off
in three years that would be the goal if
they did this move it would be how fast
can we pay this off yeah to get put it
on you know 100 000 a year because you
just increase your household income by
70 the other day so I think you could
put 100 a year on this and probably
still do investing but I I would have to
and if you were saving to buy how deep
would you sacrifice to save up to pay
cash so that you could do it in two and
a half years rather than four and a half
years
you know if you just put a little
thermometer or savings thermometer on
the refrigerator and you colored it in
right made it a big goal how fast could
we get there because that's honestly how
we do everything
we can't do it until we can see how we
can pay for it
because we don't borrow money because I
just
can't go back
to having anything in my mailbox or my
inbox that looks like a bank no more
payments I just can't do it I just life
is too good I've been free for too long
I mean it's a little bit of slavery okay
would you yell at me for some slavery no
I'm not gonna yell at you but I'll be
sad
for your slavery well once you live
without that payment I mean it's it's
not what would Dave do that's not the
point it's not me I mean it's you know
why did you do all this work to get to
hear
and then when I go back
after you got here I just it feels like
where it feels like we're you know you
know
I lost 600 pounds is it okay to eat a
box of donuts yeah but probably not
gonna give you what you thought it was
going to give you you know
and it's just um probably not going to
feel good when you finish you're
probably gonna wake up with like a sugar
hangover a little regret yeah it could
happen
you know I haven't had a drink in 10
years I used to be an alcoholic but I
think I'm gonna try some bourbon tonight
you know I mean I just don't get it it's
okay
it's dangerous yes I don't know if those
metaphors play or not I'm sorry for you
people in the addiction field but yeah
oh my gosh yeah but there's something
there I just
um and it's y'all don't need my
permission out there or George's
permission to do stuff we're just trying
to give you principles and guidelines
that are your shortest best route to a
great life of wealth and prosperity we
want you to be there and we want you to
stay there when you get there so I don't
know I'm
uh but yeah technically we don't tell
people
um if you wanted to go upgrade the house
and take on a people do it all the time
they do it all the time and then they
turn around but I gotta tell you you're
probably going to hate it so much you're
probably going to go bananas and pay it
off really really fast
because it's probably going to drive you
drive you which again if you stay there
with five kids you're going to want to
save up really fast to go we got to
upgrade this thing so either way it's
gonna happen yeah I think that's the
that's the way we do it is it and either
what happens is we either get
increasingly motivated and cut deeper
and deeper and deeper and deeper to get
to things sooner or to get to that goal
sooner or we um
or we get decreasingly motivated and we
realize we didn't want it and we
abandoned the goal one of the two the
last time we did this that I can
remember where we cut at the Ramsey
Place really really really deep uh was
about
gosh I'm trying to think is probably 15
years ago when we bought what is
financial peace Plaza oh yeah our old
headquarters our old headquarters and I
bought that building for five million
dollars and it was the first time I had
bought something that expensive and
there was a timeline to that right yeah
and I had I had I had to close it by a
certain date I had an option on it and
if I didn't close it by that date I was
not going to get it and by the time the
date was up the building was worth 13
million and I had it tied up at five wow
so I had eight million dollars on the
table that's some incentive that I was
going to walk away from if I didn't come
up with the money but I wasn't willing
to borrow it man we we scratched every
nickel out of the corner of the couch we
turned couches upside down and shook
them you did a GoFundMe before it wasn't
cool we did everything and we barely
closed on that building but it was but I
would have walked before I went into
debt I would have walked away from it
you're crazy Ramsay yeah crazy like a
fox this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
thank you
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America I'm Dave Ramsey your host Common
Sense here
it's so rare now that having it is like
having a superpower
Vivian is with us in San Antonio Texas
hi Vivian how are you
I'm great how are you guys better than
we deserve what's up
so I'm an undergrad student right now
and I found you guys through my sister
about a year and a half ago but I
actually just recently started listening
to you guys every morning and so my
question is is that oh no thank you you
guys have really taught me a lot and
it's kind of made me a little bit more
aware of my financial situations and I
plan to go to medical school in 2025 and
I'm unsure where I want to go right now
but Texas seems to be the best bet just
because it could be cheaper and I I like
Texas overall but I want to feel more
confident in my financial my financial
situation so my question is how can I
set myself up for Success knowing that I
have about forty thousand dollars in
undergrad debt right now while I plan to
go to medical school
wow good for you and so you're currently
working on your undergrad
yes okay how's your GPA
it's good so I'm hoping to get my
science GPA up a little bit more to be
more competitive to kind of have more
options for medical school yeah you're
gonna need four you're gonna need a 4-0
aren't you
well you
know okay that's why I asked and uh how
much do you have left in your undergrad
I have one semester left all
and you're so you'll graduate this
Christmas right
yeah are you going this summer and
you're graduating in September what are
you saying
I'm sorry you're going to graduate this
coming September or this coming December
December okay all right so about six
months from now you're gonna be done and
that's 2024 and then 2025 is med school
what's the gap
the Gap is just to kind of put some
money together that way and build on my
resume that way I can actually be more
competitive like volunteering getting
shadowing experience and getting them
good for you there's like a pile of
money very very well done I love your I
love your plans enough love your plan
and you're going to clear the 40 Grand
while you're doing that you can clear
that living on nothing can you live at
your parents house while you're doing
all this
no my parents actually live in a
different state so I'm on my own over
here oh okay uh I do have low rent so
that's something that has been going for
me lately and you and you're not afraid
of work and you are a planner I like
this conversation so far so what is med
school going to cost
I'm not sure so usually they
set to like 30 000 a year or no that was
50 000 a year or so depending on the
place I go I'm hoping that I can go to a
place that has like maybe 30 000 and
that way it won't be so much and plus
San Antonio has low cost of living thank
God so that way I can hopefully just get
things under the belt it's a great City
you're in a great place so um all that's
a good plan
um well the thing I want to do is
exactly what you're doing
um to start with most people who are
want to go into Medical School are so
desperate to go to medical school that
if someone accepts them regardless of
the cost they go oh that's it got it God
is here I'm going you know and so
instead you're going I think I'm going
to shop for a better deal I like your
plan a whole lot better exactly yeah
it's a much better attitude a much
better approach that's going to save you
150 or 200 000 your attitude will yes
I'm hoping so no it will it will because
you're not going to do it if you don't
and so we're going to pile up a pile of
money we're going to clear the 40 Grand
during the Gap year we're going to apply
and until we get into a place that is
the least possible expensive to get a
medical degree which by the way that
doesn't hurt you I've been to a lot of
doctors in my life I've never once asked
one where they went to med school
that's mostly just marketing that's
mostly I can't even read the font on the
frame in my doctor's office
okay let alone figure out where he went
he just has good bedside Manner and I
trust him yeah that's all depends on I
mean obviously if you're going to do
research in some kind of monkey muck
situation where you go to school might
matter but if you're going to practice
medicine
um and no one asks the nurse no one
asked the lab tech no one asked the
anesthesiologist right before they stick
in the needle where they were they
trained they just go are you going to
kill me or are you going to heal me
that's all we want to know yes right and
so that all joking aside that's the most
overstated bunch of garbage in the world
where you went to law school or where
you went to med school sorry boys and
girls but there's life and now so you're
going to go where you can afford to go
the most now so we've at a minimum you
have limited your student loans to
almost nothing the second thing the
second component of that I think is
already built into your plan after
talking to you because you're wise
beyond your years is is that a whole lot
of people when they're doing graduate
work
um um
feel like uh there's no reason not to
borrow the money because they're going
to make a lot of money later
and so they they about as much as 50
percent of student loan debt undergrad
and grad goes to Lifestyle not to
education
so people spend like they're in Congress
when they're in school
and uh you know I used to when you went
to school you lived like a poor man's
life while you were getting your school
and you're just trying to scrape
together the nickels for the tuition now
we borrow enough to rent the apartment
with a skylight a jacuzzi and a
racquetball court and all of them need
to have pickleball these days too so
um but yeah that all that and none of
that Matt none of that has anything to
do with getting your medical degree so
you've already kind of got a lifestyle
thing going if you keep that going you
don't borrow money to eat
if you borrow money at all it's a few
nickels that you couldn't rub together
for something else and I don't recommend
that but that's at least going to limit
the damage that this doesn't how long it
takes the patient to recover to stretch
a metaphor so
um
then the last thing I'll tell you is
this is I would talk to every medical
establishment I could there's a shortage
of Docs
particularly in certain types of
practices and service if you agreed to
work for Hospital company of whatever
and you named it uh and and you agreed
to work in their hospital that was in a
rural environment for three years after
graduation and they paid you very well
for working there but you agreed to work
in a place where they have trouble
getting docs they might scholarship you
okay I'm gonna go shopping on stuff like
that because there's such a problem post
coveted with uh medical folk
particularly in what we call underserved
areas which would be rural areas and
inner city areas
they can't get nurses they can't get
Docs
and so ate the HCA I'm sorry go ahead
I also have a question so I do have a
Roth IRA that I haven't been
contributing I've started it no you're a
better investment put all the money in
you
exactly exactly leave it and let's
completely Focus everything on this
singular goal because the good news is
if you can graduate and pass your boards
and your doc you're gonna make really
good money if you're smart and you're
smart you're going to be someone who
maximizes this education in terms it
monetizes it turns it into a good return
yeah these especially with med school
it's like the people who say well Dave I
live in California the math doesn't
apply here the same mentality happens
with folks going to med school they go
well your plan's out the window I'm
gonna go in as much debt as I need to
blank check Monopoly money we'll figure
it out later well I mean the number of
times in 30 years I've talked to someone
like not that long ago A lady called
she's 32 years old medical doctor making
250 000 a year just she had a new baby
special needs um she wants to quit
but she's got four hundred thousand
dollars in debt she wants to quit take
care of her new special needs baby but
she's got four hundred thousand dollars
in debt see life doesn't exactly roll
out the way that you this idea that if I
borrow money it's all going to be okay
because I'm going to make money yeah
maybe until
dot dot dot called life you know and so
that's the problem with the Assumption
on this stuff
assumptions here those are dangerous
this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
our scripture of the day John 15 13
greater love has no one than this that
someone lay down his life for his
friends
Mark Twain said the trouble is not dying
for a friend but in finding a friend
worth dying for
he has a way with words that Twain
oh that's wrong Heather's in Phoenix
Arizona hi Heather welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hello thank you so much for taking my
calls sure what's up
so my husband and I are on baby step two
um but he's made it clear that once our
debt is paid off he doesn't want to
close the cards
um and I just feel like it's completely
unnecessary because we have six credit
cards
um and his argument is as long as we
stick to the budget you know we'll be
fine he uses miles and points um with
certain cards and it's just chaotic to
me to track all of those payment
deductions
um and so we're kind of at a
disagreement there
um I don't really know what to do Sal's
a husband
I wonder what we could get for him
can you get miles on that transaction oh
my gosh Heather I'm sorry how long you
all been married
uh eight years okay how long have you
been working on this
um two weeks
um we did do the well I did the baby
step two in um
three years ago and paid off fifty
thousand dollars of credit card debt by
myself in one year because he had lost
his job but
um then I'm kicking myself because I
didn't go beyond that step and
um he lost his job again in April and
we're still in the same place where we
have less credit card debt but we're not
really
um you know we didn't really go beyond
that so we didn't have the three to six
months of living expenses
um we had bought a new car last year
which I met now mad about but um you
know let me let me just tell you let me
tell you what I hear yeah okay
when I first started talking to you I
thought I heard it and now that I've
heard a little more I'm positive I heard
it
in your voice
when you're talking about him and his
behaviors
I hear fear
his behavior is terrifying you
because his job is irregular
his principles for handling money are
stupid
and they're leaving you at risk and you
know it and it doesn't make you mad it
it scares you
yeah you don't feel safe totally
yeah so this is not about this is not
about credit card information yeah this
is not about a credit cards it's about
marriage
yeah and so
um I don't know exactly what'll fix this
um
it is not unusual for couples to
disagree about everything including
money if Larry Burkett used to used to
say opposites attract then if one of you
uh if you're just alike one of you is
unnecessary so it's okay that you're
opposites and uh how old is he
5 35 okay so when I was 25 I was him
Sharon didn't get a voice she didn't get
a vote I was smarter than everybody and
I did whatever the flip I wanted to do
and she felt very unsafe
not physically unsafe not like I was
abusive that's not what we're talking
about and she had a reason to feel
unsafe because it wasn't long after that
that we went completely bankrupt because
I was a okay
that's how I can to hear this sound in
your voice because I've heard it at home
a long long time ago
30 plus years ago now
okay so
um I'm telling you all that to say
you're not wrong but I'm not also asking
you to be mean but I am telling you that
this is not a sustainable relationship
the way it's working now
it will not end well
if we don't repair and develop a better
method of negotiating things in your
house
and so uh worst case not not worst case
but a case an element could be marriage
counseling that wouldn't be a bad thing
by the way it helped me considerably
um the
the the actual facts around the issues
are are very easy to dispute but I don't
think that we're dealing with facts here
I think we're dealing with he has an
opinion and he really doesn't want you
to have a vote and you watch his
opinions play out and they're terrifying
you uh because he's so wrong he keeps
messing everything up
and so
um you know like it's laughable that you
guys are in financial trouble because of
his
um uh instability in his career and yet
he has a plan to make everybody rich
with airline miles
that's humorous it's so dumb
so yeah the I mean really
the credit card company's marketing is
working and uh I mean you know it's like
I I always laugh and say you know I
hired a personal trainer he has a eight
pack and I have a keg but but I'm not
gonna listen to him
but I'm not gonna listen to him why
would I listen to this guy I've got it
on my obviously based on my physique I
have it all figured out I mean that's
ridiculous so no I've got to listen to
Mr eight pack and if he says eat carrots
not Donuts Bubba you need to eat carrots
and not Donuts Bubba or you're not gonna
get one of these you're gonna keep that
thing on the front of you and so you
know I mean this is how this works it's
not you have to submit yourself to the
actual facts so um I want to give you
Financial Peace University because I
love your husband because I remember him
well he lives deep inside of me
and um I want to help him
and I want the two of you to go through
that class together I'm going to pay for
it
no cost to you guys all I ask is is that
you talk him into watching the videos
and going through the class with you and
tell him to shut up and listen
it'll help but it it and I might you
know the lessons are really good and
they might get through and that might be
all it takes but you also may need to
sit down with your pastor with a good
marriage counselor and you guys work on
your uh communication style because
we've been married Sharon I've been
married 41 years and she laughingly says
uh you know that somewhere around 36 of
those were excellent
pretty good track record so and I think
I know where the other ones were they
were back there in the early days and so
yeah when uh she found her voice she
says and well by God she did there's no
question about that but we'll ever for
it she now gets two votes she used to
only have no votes so now she gets two
but yeah but the uh uh anyway we're joke
about that but that's it's a it's a good
thing for us to be on it she and I I had
to learn
this proverb who can find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her and he will have no lack of gain so
if Sharon has a bad feeling about
something and she's from the hills of
East Tennessee it's a seven syllable
word a Phelan
if she has a bad feeling about something
we don't do it because it cost me a
minimum of 10 grand
not because I have to pay her that but
because I'm getting ready to do
something stupid with money is what that
means we don't give to a charity a
Ministry that we both are not in
agreement on and have peace to we don't
make major purchases that were not in
agreement and have peace about we don't
go and buy a car and come home and say
look what I did Honey or you got to go
along with my stupid stuff just to prove
you love me we don't do this we have
peace about these major moves and then
we make wise major moves and it's caused
us to become wealthy healthy and wise
one of the most beautiful Parts about
marriage is accountability and unity and
one of the hardest parts about marriage
is accountability and unity and for
eight years you guys have not been on
the same page you haven't had a vision
for the future it's just been his
schemes and his plans while you sit back
and take the brunt of this and you need
to be very clear with them that you are
scared this is not okay I don't think
this is an intellectual discussion about
credit card rewards no this is way
deeper than that this is just a symptom
for something much deeper and go through
through the financial peace course every
lesson and really make him watch and see
if you guys can get on a plan and unless
if he listens to this and pisses him off
tell me call me I'll be happy to talk to
him that would be fun I'd love to talk
to him no I mean I'm not mad at him does
that happen before you get the spouse to
call in later help him I'll help you
I'll be happy to help him hey Skyler uh
pick up and help them get the Financial
Peace University that puts a sour in the
book someday Ramsey your host will be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
if you love the show and you want a
deeper dive on your money Journey we've
got a Weekly Newsletter that gives you
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]